[Music]
this podcast has bad words
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
ryan nicodemus is on vacation this week
but don't worry we're here with malabama
and tk coleman and the rest of our team
coming up today on this free public
minimal episode we're joined by a very
funny man the comedian jamie kilstein is
here and we're talking to a listener
about quitting minimalism we also have
an outstanding lightning round question
about letting go of birthday gifts we
have a wonderful listener tip an added
value segment for you but you can check
out the full two hour maximal edition of
episode 353 where we answer four times
the questions and we dive deep into
seven simple living segments we also
have jamie apologize to all of his
ex-girlfriends but especially one in
particular so if you're watching this
you gotta check out that maximal episode
damn it
i always love you okay that private
podcast episode is out right now at the
minimalist dot com slash private your
support keeps our podcast and youtube
channel 100 advertisement free because
advertisements suck alabama who's our
first question from today our first
question comes from emily in manhattan
kansas
i always find myself caught off guard
when somebody says they are quote
unquote quitting minimalism and i'm
wondering what do you guys think when
you hear someone say that
it sounds like me i just moved and i had
to buy a ton of furniture and i was like
i'm gonna be a minimalist but i'd never
been to the store home goods before and
i was like i need a mat for every room
and i bought so many things and so i
feel like i i relapsed on on giving up
minimalism uh last week and i apologize
to everybody
well let's start there because
you know what what's funny is i when i
got this question i did realize how many
videos i've seen within the last year or
so on youtube and other places and i
think part of this phenomena is people
looking for more clicks and so they're
saying yes i'm quitting minimalism but
they're not really you go watch the
videos and they're like well not really
and so here's my analogy in tk you tell
me what you think about this so
a carpenter might quit carpentry but
they may not stop using their hammer for
the rest of their lives i look at
minimalism more like a tool than a
destination it's not about being a
minimalist so much as it's about using
minimalism simplifying my life being
intentional with my life using that as a
tool to live more meaningfully yeah you
don't have to like eternal sunshine your
hammer or your you know the documentary
uh about minimalism i i think you're
right about clickbait um i remember
when i was vegan there were so many
videos blowing up like i'm an ex-vegan
and it's pretty much
if there is a trend that seems to be
helping people you will get a popular
youtube video if you go i don't like
this popular thing and then everyone
clicks it also
minimalism um veganism
buddha
any practice
um is hard and so these youtube videos
blow up because
you're kind of always longing to hear
you know i know i was like when i was
vegan and i'm not vegan anymore and i
feel good
but when i was vegan and i was
struggling i always wanted to see a
video pop up my youtube feed of just
some like hot muscular dude be like i
gave up veganism and now like i can't
stop getting laid and i'd be like why
why why and it was mainly just because i
didn't want to do the hard thing anymore
um but i think what you're talking about
is really important so i had this moment
this week where i went to visit um a
bunch of people who were friends of ram
das and alan watts and all these
spiritual people and i feel like i felt
like i was sort of losing my way
spiritually and i was like what do i
need do i need a practice do i need an
alter like do i do i say hari krishna
like what am i supposed to do
and
the more they were asking me about my
life and where
i
am with it i realized that i have been
using spirituality in my life i have
been looking at people with kindness or
with love i have been
catching myself when i'm starting to
completely mentally spiral and be like
hey jamie are you garbage and i'm like
it's 8 a.m um but i'll catch myself and
be like hey this isn't real this is a
pattern this is a habit and so even
though i wasn't doing a practice and i
don't know what a minimalist practice
looks like right like yeah bowing down
to like your guys netflix documentary um
you know
maybe they maybe they maybe they moved
like me right like i moved i had to buy
a bunch of new stuff um that doesn't
mean that now suddenly i'm just like i
must have all the things that have
turned into some gluttonous you know
capitalist and used to call it collect
collect um i'm still a minimalist i just
needed i just needed some mats for my
place yeah i feel the same way when i
when i moved recently i had to buy some
new things that were appropriate for my
new home it's a new home and sometimes
what we do is we over correct buy a
thing yes and we're gonna and later in
fact later in this private podcast
episode we're gonna talk about your
roomba
and i returned it
i panicked okay yes
we'll talk about that later because we
have a segment called amass it or trash
it yeah now here's what i'll say though
jamie sometimes what we do is we leave
something yeah thinking that thing was
the problem when it was never the
problem at all you moved to tucson when
you left la let's talk about that a
little bit oh yeah
what's funny is i'm so scared my most
recent ex is gonna listen to this
podcast because she's a fan but now
we're gonna go one x before her to talk
about that which i didn't see coming um
what a what a surprise of nightmares
okay so i um i was dating this girl in
l.a and
it
we clearly settled for each other like
she
was fine she was fine
and i was fine and i even remember
because we were both it was the only
girl i ever dated from a dating site and
she was like i'm so glad you're not a
creep and i was like bar exceeded like i
i guess that's all i had to do right so
i was like great cool
and
you know it very clearly wasn't working
but i think we were i was so
tired of the girls i was going on dates
with she was so tired of these creepy
dudes um
and you know i'm we're i'm getting older
now i just turned 40 so it's kind of
like all right i think a lot of people
do this you're like this is the best
it's gonna get
because my standards were so low not
even for women my standards were so low
for myself and what i deserved and what
i thought i deserved and so when we
weren't working
we moved to arizona because instead of
saying hey maybe we ignored some red
flags and maybe we were just you know
good for a couple months to show each
other we deserve more and be kind to
each other and stuff like that instead
we were like no you know what it was
probably la's fault we should leave the
entire state of california that'll fix
the relationship and then we move to
arizona and then we broke up a couple
months later uh we were just miserable
in the mountains instead of miserable in
the valley and so what i'm seeing here
is sometimes you try to run away from
the thing and it simply follows you
because you're clinging to something
else yeah t.k let's bring this home for
emily so she's seeing this trend of
everyone quitting minimalism because
it's now minimalism was trendy when our
netflix documentary came out in 2016.
and it's not the cool thing for them
anymore and so they're giving up their
hammer because i'm i'm done with this i
don't ever want to use a hammer ever
again talk to me tk
for all of those who are quitting
minimalism
good
because now you can just get on with the
business of living which is what
minimalism and any other meaningful ism
is actually about
the the truest sign of mastery is when
you can do
whatever you need to do
without having to identify who you are
with what it is you do
and the true sign of a novice is that
label means everything when you're first
learning how to drive you tell everybody
you know i'm in driver's ed i'm going to
get my license you're talking about
driving more than you're actually doing
it but after you've learned how to drive
and you've been doing it for a few years
you hardly ever talk about your status
as a driver that's part of the backdrop
to just you going where you need to go
it's true when people learn how to
meditate when they start a new diet they
talk about it all the time i'm into
meditation now i'm into the keto diet
now but once you take what's meaningful
and you internalize it and it becomes a
part of your lifestyle you drop the
label and you just get on with the
business of living a healthy life
regardless of what it's called so it
doesn't matter if you're quitting
minimalism just don't ever quit doing
what's best for you doing what makes you
healthy
i love that i mean i i did drive very
well over here from santa monica i was
using my blinker
i made good time uh yeah that's dude
that's such a good point i mean that's a
joke about vegans or crossfit or and i'm
so guilty of it and par partly i do it
too to hold myself accountable because i
think i'm gonna walk away from it yeah
you know what i mean like guys i stopped
watching porn and all that this is the
first time i've told anybody and i'm so
now all of you know and so if you hear
me being like man i love porn
oh no no yell at me but like i wanted to
tweet about it and i wanted just to be
like uh the world i am doing this good
thing and like it's kind of virtue
signaling but it's also like i want to
keep doing it i want to hold myself
accountable and yeah i'm so guilty of
that the second i touch a book on
buddhism i am just launching to
everybody that i'm like well it's like
buddha said yeah when buddha was sitting
under the tree you know what i love
buddha like and it's just i don't stop
doing it well i want to affirm that too
because i think that's a good thing
because that's part of the process of
reinforcing
this new belief system or this new set
of rituals that we're trying out and
that we're trying to to to make fit into
our lives i call it new convert syndrome
the new convert is the person that's
least grounded in their faith and so
they need to talk about it explicitly
because they're wrestling with it
they're processing they're seeing how
they do this and how they do that but
after a while and you warm up to it you
start to express whatever it is you
believe in your actual behavior without
feeling the need to make everything
explicit or make sure everybody knows
you're part of that label so it is part
of the learning process but once you've
mastered it you can move from that stage
of conscious competence to unconscious
competence yeah the way i talk about
comedy the way i talk about jujitsu now
compared to when i started it's just
like the i will lie to people and say
i'm not a comedian just so i don't have
to talk about it sometimes um yeah what
a great point man emily here's what i'll
tell you
if minimalism is too extreme for you and
you don't like that particularism then
just pick your own ism intentionalism
essentialism living within your means
ism
symbolism i don't care what you call it
what we're talking about here is living
meaningfully with less getting the
excess out of the way so we can focus on
what's important we're gonna send you a
copy of our book everything that remains
emily it's a book about ryan and i
quitting our past lives walking away
from something that was no longer
serving us so if minimalism is serving
you wonderful if simplifying your life
is serving you great it shows how we
started simplifying our lives if you
enjoy our podcast i think you'll enjoy
the audiobook version of everything that
remains it's still our most popular book
to date or if you want the book book or
the ebook version of everything that
remains we'll send that to you as well
it is time for the lightning round where
we answer your text messages you can
text your questions your comments your
eggplant emojis to 937-202-4654
those texts literally go to ryan's of my
phones and eventually tk we'll get him
in on the action here as well we respond
to a lot of people just uh random
throughout the day but we also respond
to some folks
well here on the podcast looks like
lauren has a question for us how do you
handle birthday gifts you don't want
i've tried to make creative suggestions
but my family still wants to give me
physical gifts now jamie you'll recall
during the lightning round so we do our
best to answer questions with a short
shareable less than 140
me because i characters into a million
different tangents about trees every
time i try to answer a question
i'll try my best we call them minimal
maximums we put them in the show notes
so you can copy and share our pithy
answers on social media mine's like
thread one of 56.
here's my pithy answer let's unpack it
here a gift is not a gift if you are not
allowed to let it go
here's something else pithy for you a
relationship is not loving if it's not
honest so here's the thing how do you
approach someone you don't want gifts
from
you just tell them you don't want gifts
because if you can't be honest with
someone that you love do you actually
love them are you in a real relationship
with someone if you can't say hey i
don't like that that's not a
relationship that's an obligation
if you feel afraid of the person in your
life you're afraid of rejection you're
afraid of not being accepted you're
afraid of not being loved that's not
love that's conditions right and so if
someone's giving you a gift why are they
giving you a gift it's because they want
to add value to your life and that's
wonderful so you can appreciate the gift
but once you get the gift know that it
is your gift to do whatever you want
with it you can donate it you can sell
it you can put it on your mantel you can
wear it you can choose to do nothing at
all with it that's totally fine a gift
is a gift but once it's your gift you do
whatever you want with it the reason
they're doing it is because they think
that gift giving is a love language well
that's nonsense the that's like saying
pig latin is a romance language
we
give gifts because we want to add value
to someone's life so it's not about the
gift it's about the adding value to your
life and if you're getting a gift and
it's extracting value from your life
it's getting in the way of your life
that's not what the gift giver intended
they want you to feel joyous from that
thing so instead of just saying no no no
no
say yes to something else here's the
type of gift that i would get value from
maybe it's just more time with you maybe
it's a gift card to applebee's whatever
it is probably not a gift card to
applebee's watching you slowly second
guess that uh in your head was so fun
you were like applebee's and then i just
watched you go what am i gross
[Laughter]
find a good woman at applebee's man
so
it's a variation of yours
the right to give it away is part of the
definition of a gift
if someone is truly giving you something
then part of what they have given you is
the right to do whatever you want with
that thing because it's now yours a gift
is a transferring of ownership right
they bought it they own what they pay
for and now they're transfer
transferring ownership to you i'll tell
you what you don't want to do and this
will get you in trouble you don't want
to get into the business of trying to
convert someone to your religious
beliefs about how they should spend
their money and what they should do with
gifts because that's the business of
trying to control people and it's only
going to lead to frustration people are
going to spend their money however they
want to spend it they're going to do
what they want to do with gifts however
they want to do it and if you try to
control them you're going to frustrate
them and yourself but here's what you
can do here's what's within the realm of
power for you you can reject it you can
receive it or you can redistribute it
you've got those three options and that
gives you all the power you need when
someone gives you a gift and you don't
like it
you can reject it and you can just be
honest and say nope i don't want it i
don't like physical gifts end of story
if you're not comfortable doing that no
problem you can you can do the second
thing you can receive it you can say
thank you kindly and then you can employ
the third option of redistributing it
let me find someone who would really
appreciate this and i'll give it to them
don't try to control them
and give yourself one of those three
options and you'll solve the problem
every time yeah my short answer is you
just go look at how sweet it is that
they tried right i
i have a kind of a weird trigger with
gifts and it was growing up as a kid and
getting
horrible last-minute gifts on christmas
from drunk family members and just i i
i'm weird with it and so every time i've
had you know an ex give me something i
said i didn't want or whatever it like
it it hits harder and i i don't like it
about me but
ever since i started kind of going like
oh this is cute even when it's a thing
so we have we have a a
a family member who gets us very weird
gifts all me and all my siblings every
christmas and it's and at first we were
like what is this like he has money what
is he doing and
now it has become our favorite thing
where we open it at the same time to be
like what bad [ __ ] crazy thing are we
all about to get and we laugh about it
and we don't even use it and sure it's a
waste but that moment of joy where we're
just all just dumbfounded around a
christmas tree is is is worth it so you
know you're gonna have that pang
of of of
hurt or whatever it is when you see the
gift you don't want and then you just
look at them and you go even if they
didn't listen you go yeah man it's just
it's sweet that they're they tried if it
brought that joy out of you though it
turns out that it's actually not a waste
it's brilliant right exactly that's
beautiful hey real quick just a little
christmas analogy santa claus has lots
of gifts that he doesn't want and that
brings him great joy because it's not
about him an unwanted gift is an
opportunity to be generous
and so many of us say i wish i could
help people more i wish i could share
more i wish i could give more and then
we get a gift that we don't want yeah we
don't recognize that moment for what it
is and we say oh my life is so terrible
but yeah that's the answer to that
prayer right there it's an opportunity
to be generous now you can bless someone
for free oh yeah my mom was a alcoholic
so we didn't leave milk and cookies for
santa left uh beer and cookies
also funny story when i was very similar
when i was 16
i got a 16 16 16. i got a carton of
cigarettes uh for christmas and the best
part was it wasn't for my mom it was
from santa it was my stars in my
stocking uh and i couldn't have been
happier than marble mentholites cheers
we got a bunch more segments to get to
but uh alabama what else you got for us
here's a minimalist insight from one of
our listeners
hi josh and ryan this is laura calling
from kansas city missouri there's a book
called i think you're wrong but i'm
listening by sarah holland who's a
democrat and best silvers who's a
republican they have a lot of tips and
insight on how to have kind and
respectful political discussions with
people that we love but disagree with
they also have a podcast called pantsuit
politics where they practice what they
preach in their books
all right real quick uh right here right
now here's one thing going on in the
life of the minimalist jamie i don't
know if you heard about this but we
started a church without religion what
uh sort of tell me about it it's not
really a church i'm just joking but it's
is here to bring some christ then
the funny thing is ryan tk and i all
have different religious and spiritual
beliefs and ryan and tk were talking
about this and so i just sort of jumped
on board so much about this okay yeah so
sometimes people like they lack a
community especially in a place like los
angeles so we've done is we're doing
these monthly events now it's called
sunday symposium
sundays at noon the first one is august
28th it sold out in like an hour now
there are free tickets or you could pay
to help us pay for the venue so it was
an option for either but we're going to
be doing them throughout the year so
maybe we'll get jamie to come to one of
these he could even do some you know
stand up as long as it's extemporaneous
uh sure
i'll i will improvise the entires i i
will do and it fully improvised that for
you
or you have me and matt nathan hear me
out he plays some guitar and we can
banter back and forth over the music
which is kind of like my music project
that'd be hilarious that'd be great we
had him uh open at our um san francisco
show earlier this year it was amazing
and i would love to get him to come down
because we're going to have music at
these events so really what it is
it's kind of like a live podcast we do
audience q a but it's small it's a
dynasty type writer i think you've
probably been there before yeah jamie
the owner there he's amazing he and his
wife and it seats 200 people and that's
it so we're not it's not about like
filling up the 2000 theaters or whatever
it's how do we go deep with this small
crowd of people how do we build this
community and then we do it monthly for
the people are getting value from it the
first one we have amanda montel there we
have a special uh musical group the
bergamot opening up as well tk will be
there i'll be there ryan will be there
and future ones i'd love to get jamie to
come out to that as well yeah
community's so important that sounds god
that sounds awesome even like people
talk about community is important and
you know we're all divided on social
media and once you talk to people in
real life even if they disagree with you
um you know you realize you have more in
common that's all true as well but even
if you go to one of these events and i
talk about all that stuff a lot it's
important but even if you go to one of
these events and you don't talk to
anyone being i saw fish for the first
time since i was a kid
very recently and it was wild because
everyone grew up it was the same people
that i sought with but they shaved off
their dreads and they're wearing nice
clothes but then fish comes on and
they're still just like smoking weed and
dancing like hippies and it was great
and i don't think i talked to anybody
that night
but being around a bunch of people who
love the same thing or who have the same
values sometimes it's just that's
cathartic enough so i am beyond hyped
you guys are doing this we'll also be
filming it uh jordan and danny will be
there so if you're one of the true fans
vips on patreon you have access to all
of our live events including these live
events so you'll have access to that as
well so if you're not anywhere near
los angeles and you don't want to make
the trip out for it totally understand
but get on the wait list right now
because as soon as more tickets open up
and they will you'll want to be the
first to hear about it sunday symposium
dot com also i teach a writing class
it's called how to write better and i
share these quick little writing tips on
instagram tick tock
twitter youtube we'll put a link to it
actually just go to howtowritebetter.org
we'll put a link to that in the show
notes you can find all the different
social media channels and so every week
i just share some writing tips i'll do a
little video of me giving you a writing
tip something you can implement in your
writing right there it's not some
esoteric you know uh make sure that
you're um
you know the the the conjugating your
verbs approach
we're not getting into that although i
can give you some resources they'll help
you with that if you want to learn about
sentence structure but i'm talking about
something you can walk away with right
now to improve your writing you can find
all the social media accounts for how to
write better over at
howtowritebetter.org
before we get to our added value i want
to thank
jamie kilstein for being here today and
i want to encourage you to check out his
patreon because i am a patreon
subscriber oh you're so sweet i'd check
out his private podcast which is like an
extended version of his public version
of his podcast but you can check him out
either place publicly or privately this
was also me trying so hard not to curse
and i still let out some big ones um so
yeah the uh if you enjoy kind of off the
rails
stuff that also the patreon is for you i
enjoy your
you here's what you do on your podcast
you take your neuroses and you scatter
them all over the table and then you
organize them in real time isn't it wild
how i can come back to it i am very
proud of that i was on a date the other
night and she was just like
she was very similar to me and would
change subjects and i'd bring it back
and she's like how do you bring it back
like that and i was just like oh my god
podcasting just helped me on a date for
the first time ever where it's like i'm
used to just me i did pete holmes
podcast and we were both just digressing
all over the place and just being able
to oh circling back to this circling
back to that you you don't realize the
skills you pick up from this very weird
job of ours speaking of pete holmes rob
bell his friend and a friend of ours he
always says there are no tangents
and what a beautiful line because we
talk about tangents as though it's a bad
thing like oh i was on this path and
then i went down this path yeah but if
you're out in nature and you take a
tangent you just say oh i i
failed right i screwed up no i just went
a different direction also how beautiful
is edwards you just said something to me
that inspired me so deeply i'm gonna
risk derailing an entire show because i
have to get this out because i want to
share it so badly with you like that's
beautiful yeah
also follow me on twitter
[Laughter]
jamiekillsteam we'll put a link to
jamie's podcast his patreon and his
social media in the show notes so you
can follow him over there he makes some
hilarious videos on instagram as well at
the jamie kilstein for our added value
this week this is a song
by an artist named voree and his new
album is called lost angels and the song
is called
cindy's interlude and this album is one
of the most toxic albums so we've been
talking about toxicity today
what is it about toxicity that makes the
most compelling music i think it's
because there's something that we feel
within us god i would probably date this
guy this is awful
i'm gonna listen to the album it's gonna
be great
this is uh cindy's interlude from uh
voree
by the way we got a bunch more surprise
questions on the private podcast this
week like how can i better organize the
photo clutter on my smartphone how do i
make more time to do the things i enjoy
doing how can i use minimalism to help
me stay calm during a hectic season plus
seven different simple living segments
and a million more questions and if you
want to hear all that visit the
minimalists.com
private or click the link in the
description to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our maximal
episodes play in your favorite podcast
app you also gain immediate access to
all of our archives recordings of live
events weekly home tours and our private
community of thousands of open-minded
minimizers like you if you have a
question or comment for our podcast give
us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists.com you can
follow the minimalists on tik-tok
instagram facebook and twitter at the
minimalists to get our podcast show
notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list over at
theminimalists.com on behalf of ryan
nicodemus tk coleman alabama podcast
sean
jordan no more professor sean
social jets danny unknown
post-production peter m of the immigrant
we don't have a very minimalist team
jamie this is so many people
get rid of them and the rest of our team
big thanks my name is joshua fields
melbourne if you leave here today with
just one message
let it be this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it